now your birthday is around the corner
by the way this is so exciting are you
like into birthdays i am yummy too i am
so into my birthday
i want everyone to celebrate it yes and
i'm embarrassed to say i love presents
okay this is so great because i happen
to have one of your besties here with a
little surprise ally get on out here
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen she's coming over
for lunch today none other than ally
wentworth
ali's birthday was yesterday
she turned 87 and she looks great
i do it's all about water just drink a
lot of water
anyway maresha used to babysit me so for
me to come out and wish her
i love you
oh this is the coolest how fun is this
it's so fun do you want to blow out your
candles i do happy birthday to you
happy day to you
happy birthday
[Applause]
right after you made that wish i just
got pinged you were picked up for season
74 75.
[Laughter]
and we could all only be so lucky i
agree i mean don't you think it's
amazing that's awesome
good i'm having a moment ally what is it
like to be friends with marishka i i you
know i mean you guys are really close i
would love a good evening how do you
mean we're close what do you mean i
don't think we're not comfortable
together she is a
she is a big carnival of fun um she just
like she's joyful and happy and you know
she walks into a room and and lights it
up and everybody wants to be around her
you know everybody wants to be you're
describing yourself i'm sorry did you
ask
what i'm like or what marisha's like she
oh mariska's cool
no but she's um
she's the one person
anything goes wrong in your life you
call her i catch george in bed with
somebody else i call her exactly i will
handle it but she will
i know but she also is like you want to
celebrate we go away every year on our
birthday together yeah we do even though
what is what was your favorite trip not
last year
last year last year we ran into a bear
yes because this could go on the next
one please you guys both maybe we'll
invite her on the next birthday trip you
also had a birthday challenge
please it's so fun it's so fun please
don't take me all we do is laugh all we
do is laugh okay so please call her you
know my name for hers what ggt which is
guaranteed good time oh my god you
cannot be with ali wentworth without
laughing and having a good time no
matter what the situation is she makes
you laugh she'll turn it around and i
just don't understand how anyone can
have such a quick and facile brain
no one will forgive me if i don't ask
about christopher maloney what is going
to happen he's back the kiss still
hasn't happened we're all hanging talk
about coitus
like tantric
what it is
it's not quite as that was the wrong
word i do like coins i'm getting nervous
about hoyt is tourists it's it's it's
the epitome of tantric
television it's a it's a new position oh
have you tried coitus poitus hoitis
coitus it hurts my neck
you and george are so hard for you
with a scuba mask and some soy sauce and
we are in heaven
okay
talk to your tv i want to make that face
again but i can't what is ever
like i mean
what people have waited for 25 years to
watch television a little boy
i'm going to text him today and say how
do you feel about a little horticulture
um listen we're trying to figure it out
what to do
we're really trying to figure out what
to do we've done hoitasquiddus now
he is free in the show i think he's got
eyes for me i mean this is literally
what olivia benson has heard i mean he
left me in a birch for ten years i and
yeah and frightened and but he's back he
is the energy's there olivia's been in
love with him for many a year
and
i think that we are slowly uh
finding our way back to it but i want to
give him
the amount of time he needs to grieve
kathy stabler
and um all i know is that this earth is
literally going to shake when that
moment happens
that is a 25 year old
waiting to happen um please consider me
a
possible to stuff in your suitcase on
your next trip we need a financial
portfolio so when somebody new comes
they pay for the trip but anyway no big
deal
also daily
testing
and daily pap smears i literally
thank you first safety first
and then get a cup of tea yes yes thank
you i'm living for this moment marishka
ali
obviously
thursdays 9 8 central
i love you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you